when Marvel's biggest film of 2018 the
exhilarating and surprisingly sad
superhero ensemble Avengers infinity war
hit Netflix on December 25th fans were
delighted a Christmas present from the
home of heroes and the number one
streaming platform in the world a chance
to watch the super-sized flick in their
pajamas sunk into the corner of their
couch and hiding behind a bowl of
popcorn where no one could judge them
for crying when Spiderman said a tearful
goodbye to Ironman in the last few
minutes of the film who wouldn't be
excited by that
unfortunately elation turned outrage for
a vocal contingent of Marvel fans when
Netflix users discovered the infinity
war plot summary at the time the film
hit the streaming site its description
read Super Heroes a mass to stop
intergalactic sociopath Thanos from
acquiring a full set of Infinity stones
and wiping out half of all life in the
universe as it turns out some concern
movie watchers took issue with the use
of the phrase intergalactic sociopath to
describe Thanos the purple-faced despot
who committed mass genocide with a snap
of his Infinity Gauntlet adorned fingers
some felt as though the label didn't
completely fit given how subjective and
ill-defined some people consider the
term sociopath to be thus fans did what
most everyone does nowadays when they
need to blow off steam and have their
thoughts heard they headed to Twitter to
air their grievances in true Festivus
fashion one wrote isn't that os-- a
psychopath not a sociopath please
correct me if my dumbass is wrong
another had this to say does this mean
that Thanos knows that what he's doing
is wrong but is doing it anyway because
he's stubborn does he truly believe that
wiping half of life from the universe is
key to saving it one Marvel fan was
certain that Netflix royally messed up
and classifying Josh Brolin's mad Titan
as a sociopath tweeting really take
issue with Netflix categorizing Thanos
as a sociopath he's clearly not of
course until we get fan o's on the couch
it's difficult to say with absolute
certainty whether the mad Titan has a
diagnosable personality disorder at all
to summarize the two disorders in a not
at all scientific way the generally
accepted difference between psychopathy
and sociopathy is that a psychopathic
individual will not feel empathy or have
a sense of morality meanwhile a
sociopathic person by contrast does have
a sense of morality having the knowledge
that a particular action is bad but
going ahead and doing it anyway but
despite these different
is the two terms are frequently
conflated and because none of us at home
can truly know whether Thanos felt bad
about eradicating half the universe's
population or if he knew that it was
wrong but still did it anyway it's not
hard to see why some fans have confused
the alien megalomaniac for being more of
a remorseless psychopath than a regret
refusing sociopaths want to see more of
this debate of course you do
back to the tweets he's a far more
dangerous villain than a sociopath he's
obsessed with his own power and believes
what he's doing is right another fan
responded tweeting that's actually a
psychopath sociopaths can feel empathy
and regrets but ignore it to achieve
their goal psychopathy is the absence of
or impaired empathy during the movie
they nose did exhibit signs of remorse
especially when it came to Gamora
a sociopath is what he is he cried he
showed remorse people are confusing
sociopathy with psychopathy psychopathy
is the absence of remorse or empathy as
tired as you probably are of this
discussion imagine how everyone else on
the internet felt the result of the
exhausting back and forth between the
tweeting armchair psychiatrists was that
many outlets on the Internet started
reporting that Netflix had actually
changed the description of the movie to
remove the word sociopath instead
describing Thanos as invader Annihilator
so-called Savior of course as of the
making of this video
opening up infinity war Netflix reveals
the same sociopathic language as ever at
least for some users it's unclear if
these reports seem to indicate that
Netflix has slowly begun rolling out a
change synopsis or if some people are
just getting confused by the two
descriptions that Netflix includes on
all of its movies just like the debate
between whether Thanos is a Psychopaths
and sociopaths this question is likewise
pointless and frustrating it is indeed a
truly perfect note to close out the year
of 2018 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]